hey guys it's max today i'm excited to
finally compare the brand new 13-inch
macbook pro with apple m1 processor
to apple's 16-inch macbook pro and we're
not only going to take a look at the
standard cpu and graphics performance
we're going to look at things such as
logic pro xcode
photo editing video editing we're going
to run some applications that are not
yet optimized
for arm we're also going to look at
thermal performance
with this thermal camera and fan noise
and along with that
both of these macbooks have their
batteries completely charged at 100
and we are going to be doing a battery
life comparison as we're doing
all of these professional tasks and
tests so i just unplugged
both of these and the 16 inch macbook
pro actually has a battery that is 70
larger than the one in the 13 inch but
of course these new chips the cpu and
graphics are so efficient
so i'm excited to test that out i'll
have links to both these macbooks down
in the video description
below we have the same amount of ssd the
same amount of
ram with these and we have a 700 price
difference but of course
there are sales right now so go and
check that out and let's start out by
talking about
the exterior differences obviously you
guys could tell that the 13 inch is
much smaller it's also three pounds
instead of 4.4
and i love traveling and going places
with the 13 inch
the 16 inch is a bit cumbersome but i've
always taken this one
because i wanted that extra performance
both of these have two usbc
ports on the left hand side but the 16
inch has two additional ports on the
right hand side which is really nice for
connecting extra accessories
displays and just having the ability to
choose which side you want to charge on
is really nice
now there probably will be a four port
model that's going to replace the 1800
base spec in the future but for now we
just have this one
and along with just having two ports you
can only connect one external display
at least a wired one you could still
connect to your ipad or
airplay or even get a usb adapter but
the 16 inch one can connect to more
external displays
let's open these up and you guys could
see that the new m1 macbooks they're
instantly on just like your cell phone
whereas with the 16 inch it took a
couple seconds to turn it on now both of
these have apple's
updated magic keyboard which has more
travel it feels a lot nicer
so there's no difference there there's a
difference on the sides of the keyboard
you see we have much larger speaker
grilles on the 16 inch and we're going
to compare speakers here in just a bit
both have touch bars with dedicated
escape keys we have touch id to log
in and then below we have the same style
of trackpad these track pads are
absolutely amazing
the 16 inch one does have a much larger
trackpad
but i have not had any issues or
limitations when i go to use a 13 inch
with a smaller trackpad taking a look at
the displays
we have 5.9 million pixels on the 16
inch
and 4.1 million pixels on the 13 inch
but that is just because we have a
larger size
so the actual sharpness and detail is
identical the same thing goes for the
brightness both
a nice bright 500 nits color accuracy is
also
identical so you're not really losing
anything with the 13 inch
other than the smaller size i will say
when i'm doing video editing
it is nice to have the 16 inch size the
extra screen but for a lot of other
tasks
the 13 inch is just fine before we get
into performance i want to get a
baseline reading on the temperature so
it looks like the 16 inch
the hottest part right now is about 28
degrees you guys can see
that looks like to be the touch bar but
it's pretty even as far as heat we
haven't really done much
and then with the 13 inch looks like
26 degrees or so and that's part of the
touch bar if you guys are interested in
this thermal camera i'll go ahead and
link it down below as well
and as far as the cpu temperatures we
have a nice cool 30 degree celsius on
the 16 inch
and 23 degrees on the new m1 which is
shockingly cool
now i love the speakers that are in the
16 inch macbook pro there are six
dedicated drivers in here sounds
phenomenal
so let's go ahead and compare it to the
13-inch and see how much
speaker quality are you losing if you
downgrade go ahead and put on a pair of
headphones and let's take a listen
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comments section
below and of course we have a massive
difference now i will say that this
13-inch mac pro doesn't sound bad if
you're listening to it by itself
it's loud enough it sounds good it beats
out a lot of windows laptops
but of course when you have six
dedicated speakers it's much louder
it's richer the bass is better the highs
are more clear
it is just on another level now both
these macbooks have 720p
cameras and this is the quality of the
webcam and the microphone from the 16
inch macbook pro and i am in studio
lighting
so it's probably the best quality that
you can expect and here is the m1
13-inch macbook pro apple says that the
new image processor in the m1 chip is
supposed to improve
the video quality and they also updated
the mics but how does it compare
to the 16-inch both in terms of video
quality
and then microphone quality because the
16-inch has studio quality mics go ahead
and let me know
down in the comments section below now i
know that we spend a ton of time
on the web so i'm going to run this web
browsing test using
safari now if you're a chrome user
chrome is actually
updated for arm that is released and
it's
almost as fast as safari very little
difference
and this is going to test out the cpu
performance here
and here are the scores we have 128
compared to 220
so about 70 percent faster web browsing
performance i know it might sound weird
if you're trying to be fast on the web
but i have noticed a difference when i'm
opening up links
launching safari new tabs everything is
extremely fast
on the new m1 processors now if you're
using chrome on
the macbook pro 16 inch it is slower it
gets about 90 ish
and on the m1 it gets about 210 so still
very fast
now let's get into processor performance
i'm going to start out with geekbench
5 and i'm going to hit run and this
macbook pro it is a 2400
model we have six cores that all run
fast whereas with the m1
we have four power efficiency cores and
then four high performance cores
so let's go ahead and see how they do
all right guys we have our results
and this is incredible as far as single
core performance
the m1 macbook pro is 69
faster insane and then multi-core
it's still about 37 faster
and this thing stayed silent stayed cool
it barely reached 45 degrees whereas
this one would spike up to 90.
the fans are still quiet though for that
low workload
now let's go ahead and close this and
test out the graphics i'm going to use
geekbench 5's
metal test and graphics is where the 16
inch
should stand out because it has a
dedicated graphics chip
that is built into here not just built
into the cpu
all right we have our results and this
is crazy i mean i've seen this already
obviously
but the 16-inch macbook pro it is more
powerful with the big sur the latest
version
we have 23 400 compared to 21
850 so the 16 inch is
7 faster now with the previous catalina
installed
they were almost neck and neck so it
looks like the new drivers eked out a
little bit more performance
but this is crazy that an integrated
graphics card and we'll see
how much wattage it uses in just a bit
is able to get
this much graphics performance and we'll
also see how
it compares in real world testing now
before we push these machines to their
limits i want to take a look
at the battery life and it's interesting
so we have
97 battery on the m1 macbook pro the 13
inch
92 percent on the 16 inch and it says
that the display is using
significant energy even though i
actually have them
at the exact same brightness it looks a
little bit different because we have a
different wallpaper on here
maybe it's also because of the larger
display and now let's max out the cpus
and see what kind of performance we can
expect when you're rendering
transcoding doing things like that i'm
going to go ahead and start
our multi-core test here and for
the 16-inch macbook pro i have intel
power gadget open to see
our wattage it doesn't work on the new
m1 max
and right away 89 watts
look at that 90 watts we're peaking 91
so the wattage on the six core just went
through the roof to get the maximum
performance that we
can of course with that you guys see the
temperatures just shot up like crazy as
well
and then now it's sitting about 66 watts
as we're going through this test
and if we look at the m1 um they i can't
use that but i did find the terminal
command
so this actually reports all the
statistics
and we are using 12.9 watts basically 13
watts right now
compared to 67 watts a massive
difference
in how much power we need to do this
test and if we
look it actually looks like the m1
macbook pro is ahead
on this test now i'm starting to hear
these fans spin up we're at 95 degrees
celsius
on the 16 inch on the six core whereas
with this one it's silent it is
completely
silent and as far as the wattage and
frequency
everything looks to be staying the same
12.5 watts
we're still running at two 3.2 gigahertz
and over here we are running at about
3.6 the m1 just got done with its first
run and this test cinebench r23 will do
10
minutes and then finish up with the last
run to test out thermal throttling
performance
we're at 99 degrees celsius right now
100
in this on the cpu and i'm really
hearing the fans
run it looks like they're about 85 now
86
give another 20 seconds or so they're
going to be maxed out and we're still at
94
degrees celsius compared to the m1
65 degrees celsius that's it we're five
minutes in
let's go and take a look at our thermal
camera
looks like we're seeing all that heat by
the touch bar and the
keys and we're getting about 42 degrees
celsius on that keyboard that is really
hot let's look at the m1 mac
here we are seeing the hottest point
is 36 37 or so
we're almost under the test and the m1
macbook actually
lapped it and it's getting close to
lapping it twice
all right guys we have our results and
wow so we have 70 127
on the 16 inch and 7705 on
the 13 inch oh my goodness this is like
cool
wow this is i just touched it not on
purpose
i guess all the heat is just heating up
the bottom area as well
so the 13 inch macbook pro is about 8
faster
in multi-core 100 cpu performance
compared to the 16-inch and not only
that obviously it ran
completely silent and much cooler all
at the same time and to get this level
of performance
it used 13 watts for the cpu slightly
less
compared to roughly 65-ish watts
let's see the difference in battery life
wow we have 90
battery life on the 13 inch m1 powered
macbook pro and on the 16 inch we're at
72 now now what about gaming performance
for those of you guys that want to have
some fun
after work is done i have gfx bench
metal opened up right here and it has
been
converted to work properly with these
new macbooks so we can get accurate
results
i'm going to go ahead and select a test
that is off screen so we have
no difference in the screen resolution
that won't affect it
and let's go ahead and click start now
as this is starting up and
is running which the macbook pro started
almost instantly
we're waiting on the 16 inch right here
to initiate the test
um i want to talk about the wattage for
the graphics we just looked at it
for the cpu and this is concerning me is
it not starting
okay there it is it started just took a
while um so
what really shocks my mind when we got
that 21 000 metal test
in geekbench 5 the chip the graphics
chip that's built into the cpu and the
ram
all together it only uses 5.6 watts to
achieve that
whereas the 5300m in here
uses about 40 45 watts
in order to achieve its maximum
performance which is absolutely crazy
alright and this is something i was not
expecting
we have 77 frames per second on the
m1 macbook pro and on the 16-inch with a
dedicated graphics card that was using
55 watts instead of 5.6 it got 86.9
that is 12 and a half percent better
gaming performance under
metal that is crazy i thought the 16
inch would do a lot better than that
when we give it a lot of performance it
can run great and
the fact that it's unplugged actually
doesn't matter i've tested it
um a ton of tests unplugged and plugged
in this macbook pro
has no issues wow that is such a small
difference in graphics performance and
this is the first
m1 chip with the weakest graphics that
will ever come out
so that is just mind blowing to me
all right let's go ahead and shut this
down and let's get into some more
real life professional uses all right i
have logic pro opened up right here
we're gonna see how these two
compare and if some of you guys can just
downsize now
maybe actually make some money if you
sell yours in the advanced settings i
have the i o buffer size to 1024
for best performance and then as far as
the processing threads
i want to make sure i max them out so on
the six core processor we have 12
threads but interestingly this is an a
core
processor and it only lets me select if
i want to use
two high performance cores or if i want
to use four high performance cores i
don't know if it's not using the
efficiency course
who knows but that's how we have it set
up so let's go ahead and close this down
now i have 95 tracks enabled right now
let's hit play okay
the 16 inch overloaded right away
is unable to process all of that
our m1 is still going strong the cpu is
at 79
right now all right so i know that this
is about what it can max out at
because we've already tested it i have
no idea what the 16 inch can handle
so how about we drop down to say 80
and we over loaded at 80.
the m1 is almost done with 95 and in our
tests
we got about 95 sometimes 93 maybe
slightly more
which is extremely impressive for a
system that costs that low
let's try 70 on the 16 16-inch we're
two-thirds of the way through the cp's
at 77
percent oh man our our cpu is at 98
degrees celsius
is it gonna crash if it starts
throttling are we almost there
there you go we made it through 70
tracks let's try 75 i hear the fans
spinning up now it's running hot the
fans
are getting loud let's see what they're
at right now 88
90 so they're gonna max out here any
second or 94 degrees celsius
oh and it crashed at 76
tracks with the fan spinning at full
blast
really hot so it looks like 75 tracks is
the most that it can handle
whereas this much less expensive smaller
machine handles 95 now
now the previous version of this macbook
pro actually handled
under 10 tracks when they're set up
exactly like this
so now let's go ahead and open up xcode
this is a benchmark made for us by maxim
eramenko
all right let's hit build our cpus are
completely
maxed out right now and looks like
the m1 even though i started it later
look how much
faster it is building in compiling this
code
the m1 is almost done here we're maybe a
third of the way through we're at 90
degrees celsius our
fans are running at 73
right now so it's definitely getting hot
and our build succeeded
on the m1 and the build just finished
on the 16 inch wow this
is just sad i feel sad for anybody
that just bought a intel mac
man this thing is just hot to the touch
even here it took
210 seconds to compile this code
and the 13 inch macbook pro took 123
seconds all while being silent
running at about 60 degrees celsius cool
to the touch
and it finished 70 percent
faster that is absolutely insane and if
i was somebody that would
was working with code right now
especially in xcode i
i would be getting rid of my intel base
max right now this is just
absolute it's an absolute slaughterhouse
at this point
all right so now let's go ahead and
switch over to lightroom
for some photo editing wow that's crazy
the m1
actually launched it a few seconds
faster than the 16-inch macbook pro
and just so you guys know this
application has not been
updated for apple silicon it is actually
optimized for
intel systems and it's using rosetta to
translate it so we are losing
performance
let's go ahead and just get started with
a simple test zooming in
these are 42 megapixel files from a
sony a7r 3 and they
are graded you guys see we have
adjustments made on these raw images
so as far as punching in here i see no
smoothness at all
now one area where people get frustrated
and they really get slowed down as if
they're switching between files
especially
these super high resolution files it can
get really slow
and as you guys could see the six well
actually that time the m1 is faster
okay it's 16 inches faster m1 is faster
i'm pressing is at the same time that
time the 60 inch was definitely faster
about the same all right well i guess
it's kind of neck and neck in some cases
the 16 inches faster some cases the 13
inch
where pretty much no difference and
every time i switch it has to load all
of these changes there
now let's go ahead and grab a brush here
and we'll compare some of the brush
performance so
i have an exposure brush this is really
hard to do
at the same time but as you guys can see
both of them are nice
and smooth let's go ahead and try that
one more time
okay on a lot of systems um you'll get
some stuttering some slow down some lag
i'm not seeing any difference there not
bad and now let's go ahead and export
both of these
50 sets of images to jpeg all right
we have our results and i have to say
i feel bad for you 16-inch macbook pro
i thought at least in this test you
would reign supreme but jeez the 16-inch
took
three minutes and 10 seconds which is a
great time it is a great time
the m1 took two minutes and 44
seconds that means that this m1 even
without the optimizations for arm
processors
it's still an intel optimized app it's
slightly higher than 15
faster at exporting um these
clips this these photos whatever i'm
just i've done way too much videos
lately
it's faster editing performance is very
similar
and as soon as it's optimized it's going
to get even
better which is crazy so
if you're a photo editor you no longer
need a 16 inch
unless you want the larger screen size
for me though the screen size isn't as
important as video editing so now let's
go ahead
and close down lightroom and let's open
up
final cut pro wow it's incredibly crazy
how quick apps launch i mean it's not
that slow you guys could see
i mean maybe took three times longer on
the 16 inch
but with an optimized app that is just
instant now i am
very curious to see what we get with
bruce x
because we have this dedicated graphics
card that has more
performance in metal and what are we
going to see in final cut and this test
right here
uh it will actually give you guys kind
of some numbers to go off of on
how well the system can render your
color corrections
titles effects generators transitions
all those kind of things that the
graphics
has to handle and we are off and this is
crazy we're at 37
compared to 33 40 51 compared to 45
all right guys that was quick and the 16
inch actually
finished first uh it took 22 seconds
compared to 23 on the m1 so one second
difference it actually caught up at the
end there that is still extremely
impressive for the m1 to put into
perspective
the laptop the macro core that it
replaced that came out just six months
ago
took 67 seconds so that is pretty much
three times as long
as this new one that is insane next i
have a 4k
project opened up right here and let me
hit play
this is playing back at full quality in
the better quality mode not better
performance
and i also have two let's applied and
also film gray now the previous macbook
pro that the m1 replaced
could not play this back it would start
stuttering like crazy but as you guys
could see
it is playing back perfectly just like
the 16-inch macbook pro
and i'm gonna go ahead and export this
five minute project let's hit
save here and we are off the 16-inch
macbook pro
took three minutes and 36 seconds for
this five minute project
on the m1 it took three minutes and
six seconds basically 30 seconds
faster of course this thing is still
spinning up the fans
you guys hear that this is trying to
cool itself down
and once again to put that into
perspective the previous
macbook pro 13 inch took roughly 12
minutes
now another difference that i noticed is
battery life
right at the end there i checked at the
battery life we're at three percent
battery and i know some of you guys are
going to worry hey the result might not
be correct
actually it is it actually matches up to
our previous testing exactly
macs are great if they're unplugged they
perform the same
but we're now at three percent battery
it has been close to three and a half
hours we've been shooting
it's actually not bad a lot of witness
computers will tap out after about an
hour and a half doing this kind of
workload
unplugged so three percent go ahead and
take a guess down in the comments
section
what the battery life percentage is on
the m1 mac
pro doing the same exact tasks
take a guess pause the video this is
going to be fun
okay let's go ahead and take a look i
mean i see the status icon there
67 67
compared to three percent this battery
here
is 70 percent larger
this battery is way smaller and
basically we only burn through
a third of the battery in three and a
half hours of pushing it like this
all right let me go ahead and plug these
back in at least let me just plug in the
16 inch i
don't have to plug this one in and let's
keep going these are 10 bit files from
the canon r5
4k 30fps c log i'm going to go ahead and
hit play
and i already know what's going to
happen
pretty much every graphics card and
every system right now doesn't have
decoders
for this kodak and this footage is from
the canon r5
r6 the new c70 a lot of new canon
cameras are using it sony can shoot it
it's a great file but look how tough it
is to play back we got all that
stuttering
compared to perfectly smooth playback
because
the gpus inside the apple m1 chip
they have special decoders you guys see
how smooth that is compared to this and
not only does the 16 inch
really struggle with this footage same
thing with my 15 000
mac pro here's a little clip of how that
plays back this footage it looks
just as horrible as this and now of
course that stays cool we're at 99
degrees celsius right now trying to play
this back
here we're at 30 degrees celsius that is
insane now of course you can transcode
this footage to prores and play it back
so let's do a quick transcoding test
let's hit okay
at the same time i'm going to start my
timer here
and oh my goodness that thing's already
off
all right we're at five percent here 24
28 that's for the first clip
oh my goodness second one's almost done
bam all right
fast that was fast so the
16 inch right now is at 28 29
all right we are done on the 16-inch
that took a minute and 39
and a half seconds so basically about a
minute and 40 seconds
to transcode one minute of 4k 30 footage
and the m1 macbook took 26
seconds the m1 macbook air is more than
three times
faster at transcoding this footage now
for those of you guys that want a lot
more testing if you want to know about
premiere pro davinci resolve
black magic raw maybe pro res and a lot
more in depth
i'm gonna have a detailed comparison
between these two taking a look at all
those programs on my filmmaking channel
called max yuryev
i'll leave a link in the video
description because when i get into that
and testing that's a 20 minute video all
by itself showing you guys all the
differences in those different programs
some of them optimized some that have
not and now
finally which one of these should you
buy
and should you downgrade from a 16 inch
down to
a 13 inch well for that second question
yes absolutely now is the time there's
actually a sale
on um this machine right here on amazon
so if you want to get a discount you can
go and check it out i'll leave a link in
the video description
but if you've been waiting you just
didn't want to miss the performance even
lugging around a 16-inch which is
exactly what i've been doing
you no longer have to not only did
the this thing basically smoke it in cp
performance and match up in graphics
performance
it also is better in logic it's quieter
it's cooler
with xcode it is much faster in
lightroom even unoptimized
it is still faster and the editing is
just as good
and then in final cut as far as graphics
tasks it's very similar
and then exporting it's now faster
for r5 footage is better and then along
with that
as far as just the battery life that is
just mind-blowing
this thing is pretty much dead and this
was at 67
even though it has a smaller battery
yeah i think we
that that's the whole story right there
you guys let me know your thoughts down
in the comment section below and if you
made it this far click that circle above
to subscribe
we'll have more great videos for you
guys we're going to put this against the
imac and even my mac pro that's going to
be so interesting
you guys can help us hit 500 000
subscribers before the end of the year
thank you guys for watching it's been
max and i'll catch you in the next video